No credit card?
No problem!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you
are sick of hearing about all these credit
card and data breaches, you are not alone.
Michaels Craft Store - one of the happiest
places on earth - announced recently that
2 separate 8-month-long security breaches
at its stores last year may have exposed as
many as 3 million customer credit and debit
cards.
Between this, last year's Target breach, and
the crazy data theft that happened in South
Korea earlier this year - it might be time
to consider some alternative payment methods.
And that's exactly what one Swedish startup
is trying to do.
Quixter is a company founded by former students
of Sweden's Lund University, and it allows
users to pay for items at a checkout with
a simple swipe of their hand.
It's a new form of biometric scanning, that
uses the unique pattern of veins inside your
palm to identify you.
Unlike fingerprint scanners, which can leave
behind prints - the creators of this technology
claim there's no possible way to commit fraud
with this system, because it doesn't require
physical contact with the user.
The other obvious benefit, is that it reduces
the amount of time consumers spend waiting
in line at stores.
The hand swipe itself takes only a couples
seconds, but Quixter also requires users to
enter the last 4 digits of their phone number.
Which isn't so much an added security measure,
as it is a way for users to see exactly how
much they're being charged before they pay
for something.
Similar vein-scanning hardware has been used
in Japanese and Brazilian ATMS for years now,
but this is one of the first instances of
it being used specifically for payment processing.
US company BiYo, formerly known as PulseWallet
- was technically the first to develop this
technology - for which they claim near-perfect
results, citing one false positive for every
1.25 million scans.
Unfortunately, it may be a while before anyone
sees Quixter's technology outside of Sweden.
The system is currently active in only a handful
of locations surrounding the university's
campus - with a total of around 1,600 users,
mostly students.
The company does plan to expand their reach
- but the biggest hurdle, they say, is getting
businesses and banks on board.
Signing up as a user, is as easy as going
to a store, registering your social security
and phone numbers, and linking your bank account
online.
It seems simple enough, but I've seen a lot
of mixed responses to this online.
Let us know in the comments below if this
is something you would ever considering using.
And for more episodes of Dnews - subscribe
here.